47% c'est le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire en France ce chiffre nous
plaçant première position de la zone
euro en matière de pression fiscale la
France est donc le pays où l'on paye le
plus d'impôts devant la Belgique 46 %
l'Autriche 43,7 % pour la zone euro la
moyenne est à 42,2 où va l'argent parce
que moi ça me rend littéralement alors
je sais que le sujet c'est pas vraiment
l'impôt sur le revenu mais ça me rend
malade de payer autant d'impôts parce
que dès que vous passez sur la tranche
supérieure même si vous êtes tout en bas
vous payez énormément et moi j'en ai un
peu marre d'être le tiroir-caisse pour
payer des iPhone et des vacances à ceux
qui ne travaillent pas en fait parce que
quand dès qu'il y a une allocation après
c'est pour s'acheter d'iPhone 14 donc
moi j'en ai vraiment assez d'être une
tirelire pour les gens qui ne font rien
j'ai quelques amis Miss France Armel
Valérie Camille qui m'ont appris qu'il
fallait faire ça quand on avait un petit
coup de mou et ça passe tout de suite
quand on a un coup mou un petit coup de
mou aussi
voyez je suis venu ici avec une revue
une revue La Revue du parti politique
que j'ai fondée horizon
c'est pas une religion c'est un sujet
d'aujourd'hui
et c'est un sujet vraiment
importants
si vous avez du job vous n'allez pas un
chômage si on vous propose du job dans
le métier qui est le vôtre vous n'allez
pas
c'est une question de bon sens Laurent
Geoffrin je sais que ça vous est jamais
je réfléchi à ce que vous dites
parfois c'est pas forcément le
gouvernement est en train de travailler
là-dessus pour une fois c'est pas
forcément idiot salut
[Applaudissements]
toi on voit tout de suite que t'es pas
au romantique ça c'est sûr mais si il y
a de la dentelle et tout ça
je l'ai récupéré après
du sport parfois
[Musique]
normalement c'est dans l'autre chambre
OK
[Musique]
face aux restrictions d'eau le
gouvernement va couper les fans
fontaines
et 18h c'est faux bien sûr parce que
Camille c'est impossible et on embrasse
les parents qui devront expliquer ce mot
à leurs enfants toujours un plaisir de
rendre service je vais faire picorer le
bonbon oui alors ça j'avais jamais
entendu jamais quel bonbon alors le
bonbon ça peut être homme oui le sexe de
l'homme ou le sexe de la femme on est
ouvert ici
je vois que tu es très ouverte comme
j'ai vu ta tête à toi à peu près de
partout ouais j'en ai un sur la fesse
c'est une licorne et le dernier tatouage
c'est
La Bamba dans l'hémisphère sud je vous
aime bien
[Applaudissements]
parce que là venez ici venez ici je je
vous aime faire
veux-tu que je te prenne dans mes bras
oui
je t'en prie maintenant tu viens
d'attraper une gastro c'est quoi non mon
Hémisphère Sud
[Musique]
la quéquette tu t'es tatoué le zizi
j'ai hâte de savoir ce que c'est
un éclair
à deux sortes de pénis pardon de revenir
là-dessus mais c'est quand même un
moment fort
quelque chose et pourtant Dieu sait que
j'en ai vu hein mais comme
monsieur j'étais en train de penser à la
circoncision
c'est pas cette catégorie là il a quand
même 35 balais il me sort je me suis
tatoué un éclaire au-dessus du ZG et une
licorne sur la fesse
[Musique]
là j'ai un personnage en face de moi on
peut savoir ce qui vous fait rire
moi j'ai pas eu de chance moi c'était
une vengeance non mais attends il y a
pas que je mange ça quoi alors
excusez-nous marjolaine mais on ne voit
absolument pas où vous voulez en venir
la brochette de manioc elle a une forme
vraiment très particulière je vais pas
être vulgaire mais ça ressemblait à
quelque chose de très bizarre
j'ai mon manioc on dirait un micro pénis
non mais mdr on sait les pénis de sang
et les pénis de chair ah oui
du coup quand même Laurent parce que ça
je sais pas si
moi je crois que il faut voir avant et
après gadin
je dois être pénis
pour cent de pénis de sang et 21 2 de
chair et par rapport à tout ce que vous
avez vu Laurence a coïncide ou pas à peu
près enfin en même temps je suis pas la
sauce de la [ __ ] je vous laisse le mot
de la fin line